[Music]
foreign
good morning to you welcome to Sky News
breakfast now just 39 days into her
Premiership the prime minister is
fighting for her own Survival after a
bruising few days and another
embarrassing U-turn the week ended with
her reversing one of her Flagship
economic policies and sucking her
Chancellor and close Ally quasi-quarting
this truss announced yesterday that she
would not be scrapping the rise in
corporation tax rolling back on a key
pledge in her leadership campaign
she also confirmed Jeremy Hunt who
supported rishi's sunax bid for prime
minister as her new Chancellor but her
actions reassured neither the financial
markets nor her own MPS of her economic
credibility a Party Source has told Sky
news that a substantial number of Tory
MPS have now submitted no confidence
letters in her leadership
and the pound and government bonds
continued their slide so more on the
financial Fallout in just a moment but
first Liz Bates reports on a day of
political turmoil
the papers are the latest to line up
against Liz truss and even her biggest
backer has had enough
after showing her Chancellor quasi
quattang the door yesterday should lead
trust resign Mr Kwa Tang it was her
future in the spotlight
and in an effort to calm the market and
her colleagues she u-turned on yet
another Flagship Economic Policy we need
to act now to reassure the markets of
our fiscal discipline
I have therefore decided to keep the
increase in corporation tax that was
planned by the previous government
this will raise 18 billion pounds per
year
it will act as a down payment on our
full medium-term fiscal plan which will
be accompanied by a forecast from the
Independent obr
cutting ties with the mini budget and
the man who delivered it
I was incredibly sorry to lose him
he is a great friend
and he shares my vision to set this
country on the path to Grace sacrificing
one of her closest allies to save
herself a show of strength or a sign
that she really has lost her way you are
the chancellor the ex-chancellor
designed this budget together in
lockstep we're told at times in Secrets
the two of you he has to go because of
the Fallout from it how come you get to
stay
well my priority is making sure we
deliver the economic stability that our
country needs that's why I had to take
the difficult decisions I've taken prime
minister
prime minister you're out of your debt
there were more questions but no more
answers after just eight minutes it was
all over
she may not have said much but the
turmoil at the top of government speaks
for itself an awkward start for the man
who will take over at number 10. Jeremy
Hunt no stranger to the top table he has
plenty of political allies but will they
join him alongside an increasingly
isolated prime minister
[Music]
in Westminster her enemies are
everywhere in the streets and behind
closed doors with senior figures in her
party privately in talks about not if
they should remove her but when and how
and in public even her supporters are
unhappy like most colleagues I think
um it was with disbelief
and certainly with despair that I
listened to what she had to say dark
days in Downing Street and there are
more to come Liz truss has only just
started but this is already starting to
feel like the end
Liz Bates Sky News Westminster
so all eye is now on the new Chancellor
Jeremy Hunt there he is arriving at our
Westminster offices in the last few
minutes I'll be interviewing him in the
next few minutes here on Sky News so do
stay with us for that
well the prime minister's latest U-turn
has prevented an estimated 19 billion
pounds worth of extra government debt
but that doesn't come close to closing
the black hole in the public finances
created by the government's mini budget
and energy support package our business
correspondent Paul Kelso takes us
through the numbers
Liz truss was forced to act by a crisis
of economic confidence in her and her
now ex-chancellor the quasi-quarters
plans for the public finances this is
how the office for Budget responsibility
said things looked before the mini
budget it shows national debt as a share
of GDP you can see its forecast to fall
over the next five years that told
markets that in due course the UK would
pay its own way but this is what the
mini budget did to that calculation it
slapped 45 billion pounds of unfunded
tax cuts plus the energy bailout and
other costs on top and the institute for
fiscal studies calculates that has left
a 62 billion pound hole that needs to be
filled a huge gap for new Chancellor
Jeremy Hunt to have to close to the
satisfaction of the markets the obr not
to mention conservative MPS now the
u-turn on corporation tax has closed the
Gap by 19 billion pounds and the 45p
rate cut worth 2 billion that's already
been ditched but that still leaves a gap
of
41 billion pounds now the National
Insurance cup which is staying accounts
for 18 billion pounds of that and other
Cuts including to the basic rate of
income tax and duty-free add another 6
billion but even if all those tax cuts
were reversed it doesn't fill the hole
and Liz truss has signaled that public
spending cuts are coming as yet the
markets are unconvinced this is what's
happened to 30-year bond yields that's a
measure of the cost of government
borrowing in this case the rule of thumb
is if the line goes up it's bad and down
is good and you can see that pressure
was Rising early in the week it's higher
at one point than after the mini budget
but it fell on speculation of a U-turn
and again on news quasi-quartang was
flying home from Washington but before
and after Liz truss's speech yields rose
that is bad news for government and all
of those worrying about their mortgages
now since the mini budget the bank of
England has been trying to prop up that
market and prevent a run on Pension
funds by buying guilts the bank spent 19
billion pounds in total of a possible 65
billion it had set aside creating a
deadline that helped perhaps dictate
political events fingers will now be
crossed at the bank and the treasury
that these steps have been enough to
restore Financial stability whatever the
cost of the prime minister's political
credibility
well the recent Market turmoil will
impact millions of homeowners new
analysis suggests more than 5 million
families will see their annual mortgage
payments rise over the next two years
according to the resolution Foundation
millions of households are predicted to
see their annual mortgage payments Rise
by an average of 5 100 pounds in the
next two years of that total increase
the foundation attributes 1 200 pounds
to the effect the mini budget had on
interest rates
and by the end of 2024 it's estimated
that 5.1 million mortgaged households or
nearly a fifth of households across
Britain will be spending more on their
housing costs than they do now
let's take a look at the papers now and
there's really just one story dominating
the front pages the Ft says the PM's
economic strategy has been shredded and
that MPS are in a state of mutiny
times meanwhile it says that the
appointment of a previous sunach
supporter in Jeremy Hunt as Chancellor
signals Liz truss's political weakness
trust clings to power it says the Daily
Telegraph the paper reports that scores
of MPS are plotting to replace her
similarly in the eye Tori MP's tell
truss it's over
the mirrors headline times up they
report on growing calls for a general
election
or the express maintains its loyalty to
the Prime Minister vultures are circling
the paper says but trust is not for
quitting
not the unusually supportive rather the
usually supportive daily mail is running
out of patience asking how much more can
she and the rest of us take is the
question they're asking there
the guardian meanwhile describes
yesterday as a day of chaos and
humiliating for the prime minister
and the son perhaps the exception this
morning is leading instead on the death
of the Harry Potter star Robbie Coltrane
which is
his headline is a giant of our screens
so as you can see there all the front
pages focusing on the events of
yesterday which included the appointment
of a new Chancellor Jeremy Hunt I'll be
speaking to him imminently he's just
preparing as we speak
and so uh here's Jeremy Hunt a little
bit earlier on
um obviously a lot of eyes on the new
Chancellor and what kind of Direction he
will take at the economy in as he takes
over from quasi-quarting who lost his
job yesterday he was sacked and found
out as he came back early from a trip to
the IMF in Washington
um also Liz trast decided to reverse
another key element of the mini budget
yesterday A reversal on the corporation
tax measure and she hopes that those two
steps will allow her to draw a line
under some of the problems that have
been perceived over the mini budget and
with a new Chancellor will allow her to
move ahead so
we can talk to him when quasi cartang
was sacked yesterday at Jeremy Hunt a
former Richie sunac supporter was not
the replacement of many expected list
trust to a point but speaking yesterday
the Prime Minister insisted that Hunter
she called one of the most experienced
and widely respected government
ministers was the right man to tackle
one of the toughest in trays of any new
chancellor has faced in decades
so I am joined now from Westminster by
the chancellor Jeremy Hunt very good
morning to you thanks so much for
talking to us here this morning good
morning Anna now the the government
under list truss has lost the confidence
of the markets hasn't it it's seen
people's mortgages costs shoot up
it's been forced into major u-turns on
key economic policy and has had to sack
the chancellor after a fewer than 40
days in the job why do you want to work
with this government
because I want to do the right thing for
the British people it's a big honor to
do the job that I've been asked to do by
the Prime Minister but I want to be
honest with people we have some very
difficult decisions ahead uh the last
few weeks have been very tough but the
context of course is coming out of a
pandemic and a cost of living crisis and
the thing that people want the markets
want the country needs now is stability
no chance look and control the markets
but what I can do is show that we can
pay for our tax and spending plans and
that is going to need some very
difficult decisions on both spending and
tax but that is what I must do now so
that people who are worried about their
mortgage costs going up people are
worried about how they're going to get
through winter with the cost of living
crisis people in the NHS who are worried
about the pressures they're facing can
be reassured that the fundamental
stability
that they they need from the government
they expect the government to provide is
there
you say you want to restore stability
but the the party and the country
actually reputation for economic
competence has been Trashed by the mini
budget hasn't it I mean has paid the
price for that by losing his job but can
you rebuild that reputation when the
architect of those proposals in the mini
budget is still in her job Liz truss is
still prime minister
well she's been prime minister for less
than five weeks um what I would say
about the mini budget is the chaos that
it's caused well let's talk about the
mini budget
um the most important element of it was
the energy price guarantee People's
Energy bills were heading for six and a
half thousand pounds this will keep the
average one down at two and a half
thousand pounds that's very important to
families up and down the country that's
staying but there were mistakes it was a
mistake when we're going to be asking
for difficult decisions across the board
on tax and spending to cut the rate of
tax paid by the very wealthiest it was a
mistake to fly blind and to uh to do
these forecasts without giving people
the confidence of the office for Budget
responsibility saying that the sums add
up and the prime ministers recognize
that that's why I'm here and what we
need now is for me to show Parliament
and the markets that we can make our tax
and spending plans add up that's what
I'm going to do and I want to say this
Anna if I may we will have some very
difficult decisions ahead spending will
not rise by as much as people would like
and all government departments are going
to have to find more efficiencies than
they were planning to and some taxes
will not be cut as quickly as people
want some taxes will go up so it's going
to be difficult but as we take those
difficult decisions
my priority are values as a government
will be to protect families businesses
who are going through a very challenging
time we'll be thinking about the most
vulnerable people this is a
compassionate conservative government
and the other thing is that we still
maintain total fundamental confidence in
the potential of the British economy we
have enormous amount we can do with a
fifth or sixth largest economy in the
world but we've remained a strong
economy because at difficult moments
like this we've been prepared to take
tough decisions and that's I'm afraid
what we're going to have to do okay and
I'm going to explore those tough
decisions what it means for spending in
a moment but first of all I want to get
a sense of the direction that you're
heading in because the mini budget has
had its heart ripped out of it hasn't it
after these reversals on corporation tax
and the 45p tax rate many are saying
that trust economics is dead so what is
next from you in terms of policy how
much of a departure will there be from
Liz truss and quati quatings vision
well
um as I said some of the things were
mistakes but the fundamental strategy
behind it all which is that we have to
solve the growth Paradox if we want
well-funded Public Services like the NHS
and to keep taxes low and falling then
we have to increase our growth rate that
is absolutely right and I also would
like to be able to cut corporation tax I
want us to have the most competitive
business taxes because that's the way
that we'll help to grow the economy but
the way we did it didn't give people
confidence that's what we have to change
and that's my job in the next couple of
weeks with the the statement that will
be coming out on the 31st of October
can the markets wait that long they're
clearly not satisfied at the moment they
think that the sums don't add up they no
doubt will want to see more details and
what will they be will that mean more
reversals on the mini budget will there
be more u-turns well I'm being very
straightforward we're going to have to
take some very tough decisions on both
spending and tax as I say spending will
not go up as much as people want and
there'll be more efficiencies to find
and we won't have uh the speed of tax
cuts we're hoping for and some taxes
will have to go up that's the reality of
the very challenging situation we face
but remember Anna we've only heard one
part of the equation we're hearing you
now about some of the difficult
decisions but also there's enormous
potential for growth with some of the
other policies that we'll be announcing
in the next few months and when you see
the package as a whole what you will see
is a vote of confidence in the British
economy this country that has four of
the world's top 10 universities as one
of the world two biggest Financial
Centers Europe's biggest technology
sector we have a huge amount going for
us but we have to do that by taking
difficult decisions at moments like this
and that's what I'll be doing
more efficiencies to find are we talking
austerity level Cuts again
I don't think we're talking about
austerity in the way we had it in 2010
when I was also in the cabinet but we
are talking about very difficult
decisions in budgets where there is
already a great deal of pressure so
which budgets which departments are
likely to be targeted well I'm going to
ask all departments to find more
efficiencies than they were planning to
find remember I ran the biggest spending
department
for many years so I know how just how
difficult it is to find those
efficiencies but we're all going to have
to play our part across the board but I
do want to reassure people my priority
as we take these decisions and indeed
the government's priority will be to
help families and businesses that are
struggling
and to demonstrate that as a country
when we go through difficult times we
understand the pressures facing the most
vulnerable people
can guarantee will maintain their
funding will the NHS still get all the
funding that was promised when the
Health and Social care Levy was
announced for example
well the government's already made that
commitment and we fully I think I
understand more than most the pressures
in the NHS and indeed the social care
system but I'm not going to make any
specific commitments about specific
departments now or indeed on the tax
side about specific taxes because we
have to look at these things in the
round and we have to make sure as we
take these very difficult decisions
we're honest with people about
situation we Face the big International
challenges we're going to take those
difficult decisions but we are going to
remember that as a country we are a
decent country we are a kind country and
we will remember the needs of the most
vulnerable people as we take those
decisions
well there's truss as prime minister
ever be able to inspire the confidence
of the markets when her Central ideology
has been such a disaster
well I think our Central ideology has
been that we've got to get growth into
the economy I think she's the first to
accept and that's the reason I'm sitting
here
uh that the way that she and the former
Chancellor went about it didn't work and
that's why we're doing it a different
way but the objective to get growth into
the economy so that we can fund the
Public Services like the NHS that we all
need so much that is absolutely Central
to me and every single one of my
conservative colleagues
and that we are going to go about with
redoubled effort because it's so
important it's it's important in the
good times but it's very important in
tough times like the times we face right
now it's interesting you talk about your
conservative colleagues I mean there's
still turmoil in the markets even after
her announcements yesterday Sterling and
the bond markets suffered if the markets
don't bring her down isn't there a high
chance that Tory MPS will
well what the country wants now is
stability
um you know as you mentioned in your
introduction I didn't vote for Liz truss
but I'm supporting her because I agree
with her fundamental plans for this
country which is to get us back growing
so we can afford all the things that we
really want to be successful but also to
be a compassionate Society to have a
really good public services and I think
that's what the country wants they want
a conservative party that is United
behind our leader and is trying to do
the very best thing for the country and
I think actions speak louder than words
that's what we're going to do heads down
over the next few weeks and months
okay Jeremy Hunt uh the new Chancellor
of the exchequer on your first full day
in the new job thanks very much indeed
for your time thank you
so plenty to pick over there with our
political correspondent Rob Powell who's
been listening in there in our
Westminster Studio too so Rob what do we
learn from the new Chancellor of the
direction of travel uh with him in the
job I think that was something of a cold
hard reality check from the new
Chancellor uh there Anna uh Jeremy Hunt
making quite clear that his primary
purpose in the treasury right now is to
restore economic credibility to the UK
restore economic stability
um as well
um he said that essentially his job now
was to show how the government can pay
for its tax and spending plans and he uh
made no bones about the fact that this
would be difficult that there would be
some very tough decisions he said that
departments would have to find
efficiency savings essentially public
spending would not rise as expecting
that departments would have to cut back
their budget you pressed him on whether
that would mean the NHS got all their
money he said that was or already a
commitment that was made but didn't make
any specific commitments that raises so
many issues around whether the NHS does
get the money it was expecting around
whether the ministry of defense gets the
increased funding that it was promised
by Liz trust during the leadership
campaign and follow on following on from
that there are the political
consequences of how do the various
secretaries of State react to the fact
that they are being told to trim their
budgets now also on the issue of tax as
well we clearly know that corporation
tax will now be going up Jeremy Hunt I
thought hinted that potentially there
could be more measures to come on tax
when he said that some taxes won't be
cut as quickly as some may want does
that mean further u-turns on things like
the cut to the basic rate of income tax
coming down to 19 pence in April next
year he also said that some taxes would
rise clearly a reference to corporation
tax there as well but I think that was
quite a sobering analysis of the
position we are in and quite a sobering
judgment if you like appraisal of the
impact of the last few weeks and of the
job that Jeremy Hunt now has ahead of
him
and and of course our viewers will be
watching closely but so too will Tory
MPS and the markets
yeah and I I think obviously it's two
two probably too early to say with
certainty but I think there will be a
degree of reassurance that is given by
that interview because what was
emphasized more than anything it was
clearly the message that Jeremy Hunt
went out there to put out there was
about restoring stability and
credibility and once again
um saying that the UK should be a
country that essentially shows how it is
going to pay for its spending and for
its tax cuts he admitted that there were
mistakes that had been made over the
last few weeks he said that it was a
mistake to fly blind in the mini budget
that's a reference to not having the obr
forecast there not having that
independent scrutiny of the plans that
unsettled the markets and went on to
unsettle so many MPS he said it was a
mistake to go for the 45 Pence
um cut as well so admitting really that
key planks of the trust agenda for the
last few weeks key planks of the
government that he has just joined were
not in the right place over the last few
weeks and essentially saying his job in
the treasury now is to try and put out
some of those fires that had been
started by his cabinet colleagues and by
his predecessor a few weeks ago and try
and restore some semblance of
credibility and stability to the UK
um economy so
um so sobering I think is the word I'd
use about that interview but also
probably humbling given that he is
essentially Jeremy Hunters essentially
said his job now is to repair some of
the Damage Done in the last month
yeah he kept talking about stability
didn't he I'm sure that's something that
he will continue to talk about
um over the next few days fascinating to
see what the reaction will be but Rob
thanks very much indeed for that very
quick take on our interview with the new
Chancellor of the exchequeror Jeremy
Hunt
plenty more on that throughout the
morning of course in the meantime though
also making the news this morning at
least 25 people have died in an
explosion inside a Coal Mine in Northern
turkey officials say the explosion was
likely caused by naturally occurring
flammable gases emergency teams have
worked through the night to rescue the
dozens who were trapped following the
blast
a new video has emerged online showing
an Iranian police officer sexually
assaulting a female protester while
trying to arrest her the video filmed in
the capital Tehran has sparked outrage
on social media including from
pro-government figures who've condemned
the perpetrators female voices can be
heard in the video shouting why is no
one coming to her rescue and why are you
hitting her
schools across England and Wales are
providing unhealthier and poorer quality
food due to the rising crop cost of
ingredients the school food Association
laca found that as many as 1.8 million
children have been given less nutritious
lunches as their schools grapple with
higher prices on the shelves Skies Sadia
Chowdhury reports
I like English maths and lunch I like
the times you but when we do maths
science
especially lunch
every morning ask children about the
best part of school and many will say
lunch time in one of London's most
deprived boroughs the school meal is
often the most important of the day
we don't get hurting bellies and there's
enough energy for for learning I like
lunch because I like to get a hot meal
on the table I like to eat and also so
that I don't complain I have a I have a
tummy I have a stomach
fresh fruit and vegetables quality
ingredients and locally sourced products
could now disappear from School menus
unraveling Decades of progress
if the the impact enrolls itself and
Cascades and eventually gets to their
kitchen and we then start churning out
fast food low quality meals that are not
healthy for the children it then creates
the whole issue around the Obesity
challenge that we're trying to tackle
the challenge of unhealthy meals and
unhealthy habits that then lead to later
on in life
Caterers say the rising cost of food
will force them to abandon National
guidance on healthy and nutritious
School meals
we currently cooked from scratch
everything in our small meals but again
we might be having to consider using
some processed food some sauce mixes and
the like moving forward
the government says nearly 2 million
children have access to free School
meals and that the Chancellor's New
Growth plan will raise living standards
for everyone
it told Sky News we are also supporting
schools with 53.8 billion pounds in core
funding this year and a 4 billion pound
increase in overall funding from 2021 to
2022
I'd love to send them in Impact lunches
every day but we just can't afford to
and the whole point of School meals is
that children who come from low income
backgrounds have access to good you know
good quality food that they may not be
getting at home
at this school there's a new menu coming
after the half term holidays it is they
say a step backwards Saudia chowdry Sky
News in newham in London
while tributes have been continued to
roll in from Robbie coltrane's former
Harry Potter co-stars including Daniel
Radcliffe who said Robbie was one of the
funniest people I've met and used to
keep us laughing constantly as kids on
the set I feel incredibly lucky that I
got to meet and work with him and very
sad that he's passed he was an
incredible actor and a lovely man
Emma Watson wrote Robbie was like the
most fun Uncle I've ever had but most of
all he was deeply caring and
compassionate towards me as a child and
as an adult
there was no better Hagrid you made it a
joy to be Hermione
and Tom Felton who paid Draco Malfoy
posted one of my Fondest Memories of
filming Harry Potter was a night shoot
on the first film in the Forbidden
Forest I was 12 and Robbie cared and
looked after everyone around him
effortlessly and made them laugh
effortlessly he was a big Friendly Giant
on screen but even more so in real life
thank you mate love you for everything
now a reminder of our top story here
today a short while ago I spoke to the
new Chancellor Jeremy Hunt in what was
his very first TV interview and uh this
affected him arriving ahead of that
interview in our Westminster Studios and
he told me some really interesting
things he said that he was going to have
to make some very tough decisions on the
economy he said that some taxes will
have to go up in order to reassure the
markets that the government can pay for
its tax and spending plans and he also
warned on the subject of spending that
it won't rise as much as some people
would like he said all government
departments are going to have to find
more efficiencies than they were
planning to and he told me that Liz
truss made some mistakes in her previous
economic plans so we'll bring you more
of what he said in the next hour animal
reaction
right now though let's take you through
the morning newspapers which of course
uh went out before uh word from the
chancellor
um and we can chat through some of the
stories now with the broadcaster and
journalist afia Hagen and the commission
political commentator at Benedict as
Spence so welcome back to both of you
and as we discussed in the last hour and
all the political maneuverings
um make the front pages of the
newspapers with the sucking a
quasi-quarting and the reversal of the
corporation tax measure yesterday but
you're now delving inside aren't you and
Benedict you picked out a story in the
telegraph about the PM's plans on tax
Rises
yes this is this talks uh I am anyways
very specifically about corporation tax
and I I think is very interesting
actually what uh Jeremy Hunters said to
Skye earlier which is of course that uh
you know there are probably going to be
tax uh well perhaps not tax increases
necessarily all over the place but in
some cases there will be you know some
things that were going to be reduced as
in the case the corporation tax uh that
reduction isn't now going to go ahead
it's going to stay the same
um and that there will have to be
government efficiencies elsewhere I
suppose some people might call those
austerity measures
um and this is the thing really isn't it
you know that for all his trust was
promising you know that we would go for
growth and that there would be low taxes
ultimately her entire economic platform
or most most of her economic platform
that was worth it salt is dead in the
water you know she's no longer offering
us this this low taxation High spending
situation
and I think that that is why you know
there is such you know such a morose
mood across all of the front pages today
that she simply can't survive because
actually it was about her economic
policies that she sort of hung her coat
on and it's gone now and there's I just
don't think that there's any coming back
from that oh it is very interesting uh
truss uh said before she became prime
minister that it was things like the
rising Corporation touch which was uh
proposed by uh Rishi sunak of course her
main rival that these things would
[ __ ] the economy because they would
you know they would Stave off growth
after a very difficult winter
um it's also very interesting because of
course that's a tax rise that Jeremy
Hunt was also very a family opposed in
fact he wanted to reduce corporation tax
even lower uh than it was before Rishi
sunak put it up and now you have these
two these two individuals saying oh well
you know things are probably going to
have to change now it's going to be much
more sort of in line with uh cutting
government spending and you know I think
that that really you know it's such a
you know we use the Expression U-turn
but it is such a screeching one and that
is why I think say again I just don't
think she she is long for this political
world she's cannot control uh command
the control of her party if she is
forced to make such a massive sweeping
change to the entire ideological
platform that she was elected on well
yes and a lot of the front page reflect
at that point of view I have to say but
and we want to cover a few of the other
stories as well because we're discussing
an awful lot the politics throughout the
program but I know that you've picked
out some other issues as well after
inside at the express you picked out a
story about the the rising covert cases
yes so this is the express page 25 I
believe
um and this story basically tells us
that covert inspections have risen by 31
and that is the biggest jump uh since
June uh and most of Britain is suffering
with steadily increasing levels of the
virus and now most of these have been in
older people we've seen an uptick of
infections in older people and an optic
in hospitalizations as well and so it's
got 1.7 million households have tested
positive for covert in the last week
September 23rd October 3rd can uh
compared to 1.3 million in the week
before that and as we go winter into the
winter months uh as people are indoors
more and of course viruses spread more
easily uh we've got also flu is around
in the winter as well and so we've kind
of got this uh double bound effect that
we're going to have with more fluid
faces and and more covert cases and this
is something that we are going to have
to learn to live with as we go into
these winter months you know the covert
infection has not completely died out
um it's thought that you have perhaps
some new awareness and perhaps some
older ones as well at work causing the
uptick in these cases and it is thought
that these cases are going to rise as we
go through the following weeks there is
a bit of a lag between the actual fat
infections and Reporting because of the
time it takes to gather that data but we
could see even next week and the week
after uh more people having infections
as well yeah so it's another thing that
we all need to keep an eye on in the
meantime
um The Daily Express has a story that
you've spotted at Benedict which again
more kind of ominous noises coming out
of Russia
it is and I mean you know the war in
Ukraine has been pushed off a lot of the
front pages by what's going on
domestically and the cost of living
crisis and such but I think it is worth
revisiting this uh you we often do here
don't we talk about you know nuclear
weapons and this story is about uh
Vladimir Putin uh as the headline says
threatens Global catastrophe of Russian
and NATO troops Clash but why this is
more important I think than you know
just the standard Russian saber rattling
is it comes in the aftermath of a a bit
of a tip attack actually between sort of
Western leaders within NATO itself
Emmanuel macron tweeted a couple of days
ago that we don't want world war three
and this of course caused a quite a bit
of anger amongst a lot of NATO allies
not least Ben Wallace and and the UK the
idea that you know we're potentially you
know giving away our secrets to Russia
and and saying that there are certain
things that we won't do in certain lines
that we will allow to be crossed and I
think it raised the Specter for a lot of
people of what happened in Syria when
when Barack Obama did not respect the
red lines that he drew when it came to
chemical weapons use but why this is
significance is Joseph Burrell who is a
senior security uh Minister within the
EU has said that if Russia were to use
nuclear weapons in Ukraine uh The UU
would not uh NATO rather would not
necessarily respond with a nuclear
strike but that it would lead to the
destruction of the Russian army and you
know you have to sort of read between
the lines there you've got two very
different approaches you know Emmanuel
macron who was trying to play The
Peacemaker throughout saying we don't
want more we don't want this than the
other and other people within NATO
within the alliance saying actually you
know don't mess about with us we're
prepared to go very hard here in the
story it's interesting um Putin also
criticizes Olaf Schultz in Germany for
siding with NATO that's what that's what
the copy said siding with NATO Germany
is a member of NATO Germany is a very
important part of NATO and it is as much
as anything Vladimir Putin's actions
that are forcing The Reluctant members
of NATO like Germany like France like
turkey to side more with the more
belligerent size like Poland and the
book and I think that that is this is
something that we have to be very aware
of nuclear war is of course very
dangerous the West is not threatening it
at this moment but you know Russia is
responding to what the West is saying
which is that we won't be pushed about
here even though Ukraine is not a member
of NATO itself okay yeah and that's um
another one to keep our eye on
um in the meantime the the one headline
the one front page rather that didn't
focus on um the political machinations
Affair is the sun isn't it and they LED
on Robbie coltrane's death that was
announced yesterday sadly
absolutely this legendary actor Robert
Coltrane who died at the age of 72. and
you know a lot of people know him for
his role as Hagrid and Harry Potter were
big Harry Potter fans in my house so
that's what my daughter knows him for
but you know Robbie Coltrane was on the
stage and screen for such a long time
and I remember him in Cracker uh as the
character fit so he was incredible for
and Tutti Frutti you know this Godly
stronger about this Wayward Gothic Band
that I watched later on in life because
it was on in the 80s when I was younger
and Robbie Coltrane was such a Star Wars
Asian Queen and did so many different
parts you know started off in the comedy
scene and was this huge Larger than Life
character and he once described himself
again cracker saying I drink too much I
smoked so much I gambled so much I am
too much but I'm really a legendary
character yeah it's so sad I'm going to
re-watch Cracker I absolutely loved it
we're out of time see you both next
there thanks so much
thank you
[Music]